for a couple of years now the creators
of the curse of La Llorona have been
trying to Gaslight us into believing
that it's not supposed to be a Conjuring
Universe movie you see this headline
confirmed the curse of La yorona is
definitely not part of the original
Conjuring universe and it all stems from
this Entertainment Weekly article in
which they interviewed the director
Michael Chavez he said one of the
reasons that it couldn't formally be a
part of The Conjuring universe is that
it didn't include one of the key
producers which is Peter Safran and I
think that that is total BS because
people didn't like the curse of La
yetona as much as many of the other
Conjuring movies and if you look at the
box office it's actually the worst
performing one the reason that people
think that the curse of La Llorona is a
Conjuring movie isn't because one
presenter at South by Southwest said
that it was it's because Annabelle is in
the [__] movie it's because we see
the character father Perez from The
Conjuring universe and he specifically
references a part of his life from The
Conjuring Universe I'm not a huge fan of
the curse of laodona but to say that
it's not part of The Conjuring universe
doesn't make any sense maybe it's
because you have Conjuring characters
and it plays exactly like a Conjuring
movie let me know what you think in the
comments though curse of La yetona
Conjuring movie non-conjuring movie what
are your thoughts